I want to look at a couple of these
questions that raised some really
helpful
points for us okay how about look at
these now I hope some of you worried I
know for a fact that something good read
updates which is great but some of you
are still kind of struggling with this
so let me show you how this what the
question is find the gradient line
descent from his life I'm just gonna
throw you some gradient for now I think
most people read off the mindset it's no
big deal for greater things are a little
complicated I just want you to remember
what gradient is gradients calculated by
dream drives over much but what it means
is steepness like how steeply something
is a shadow is that really really what
kind of behavior is this lion doing now
do you notice this is all about this
entire topic air 2 is about the linear
relationships
they're called linear because there's
strength right now being it's a straight
line that means that the steepness
doesn't change it stays the same all the
way through the line does that make
sense so I should be able to compare any
points I live on this line drew this
rise over run business and that would
give me a gradient so but ones like this
it's easy because I can pick a point 3
which is on like a nice grid blank and I
can be pointy for young and I can see
all right he is the rise it goes down
since it goes down from 4 to negative 12
what is this length this is 16 right but
it's negative because it's dropping does
that make sense
I can't down I want it run how far am I
going to you now it's one square but
it's not one unit it's actually four
units watch out for that you've got to
read carefully so that is the riser 1
now that was an easy table other ones
are you know it's so simple right look
at this the numbers nothing's nice on
the gridlines
okay but you stuff to pick a point I can
still do it have a look at that halfway
between 2 & 4 3 that's 3 right and in
the same way if I went to say yeah
that's gonna be halfway between negative
four and if you're six so negative fun
so I can still calculate the rise and I
can still calculate the road in the wall
now one more thing I wanted to show you
I want you to turn back to where you
broke this okay the great is here the
gradient of one can you turn back with
person okay now I just want to add one
more thing on to this some is said of
like a quarter results the unions under
okay
I hope you've done this question already
if the ticket what I want to focus like
is this urge you okay sir said okay god
this is exactly a question I wanna
stress okay
and I Joseph right now time to do it
oh jeez a paper pickle right because
when you try and do this Rises no
problem rising from what is the rights
happy to just go through what swell to
four seats
hey wait just a made up number that
makes a lot of key comically it rises
nine how fun is it run zero
it runs zero okay now this is a problem
because if I say my name is zero what is
that now let me make a case for what it
isn't
I don't think we can say it's zero and
the reason why is because I know what a
grain is you're supposed to do it's
supposed to be know right it's this guy
down here right do you agree okay that's
great in sewer so whatever this is it's
not zero so let's just play a bit of it
this is all put in algebra right when
you don't know what something is we just
give it a name and then you see what
happens let's call it X now a division
statement like this is similar to
divisions favorite like this what's 6
divided by 3 is all very interesting
now the reason why we can say this is
because I can multiply both sides by 3
and it's still true you ruin that but 6
equals 2 times 3 does that make sense
you know now look do you remember I
don't know one night F of 0 is I'm
trying to work out what's supposed to
this I just called the X if I can do
this over here I should know do the same
thing here right sir 9 should be
x times zero hold on
I'm in trouble why am i but one thing we
know that sara is you multiply e by zero
you get zero there's no number in the
world you can stick into X so that you
get nine up the other end and that is
why we say that this is undefined your
calculator will sort of spit the dummy
oh yeah right so this point this is what
I wanted to add right underneath here
you got a puzzle to line right oh jeez a
vertical one okay Britta's here means
were the one who wanted Brady of one
beads in equation 45 degrees vertical
lines they have good gradient they can't
have a gradient because there's no run
you can't divide by zero not because
like some some math God decided we just
worked this down the everyoneís because
the logic tells you you all said to me
that this should be zero
it can't be nice Duffey you can put
there makes it nine so X can't be
anything that's what we call it
undefined and does it